[Musique]
hier en plein centre de perpignan en
marge d'un rassemblement contre le pass
vaccinale des manifestants frappe tout
vitres de la permanence du député la
raim romain grand effectivement l' usine
a fermé on s'est tous fait licencier
mais une ford avec nous on pense une
complicité des pouvoirs publics
malheureusement donc bella je me
retrouve au chômage officiellement ils
pointent à pôle emploi
après les insultes les intimidations
les lui sorti au devant des manifestants
tentent de discuter il est bousculé
d'élections aussi paradoxal que cela
puisse paraître c'est un moment où on se
bat et ou en tout cas on fait entendez
et de la révolte et on a envie de
bousculer les choses de faire chier
aussi après une demi-heure de tension un
voisin lui même griffé au visage après
un échange de coups s'interpose et pour
protéger les lui le fait rentrer chez
lui
fureur de la foule vous êtes cinq avoue
partager un espace qui est celui de la
gauche radicale j'ai l'impression de
moyens dote de français de gauche plus
être candidat à la présidentielle la de
gauche
alors comment répondre
il n'y a aucune impunité il n'y aura
aucun laxisme on peut pas considérer que
c'est banaliser absolument pas ça la
réponse d'ordre public est nécessaire et
judiciaires aussi je voudrais faire
venir dans mon gouvernement jean pierre
pernaut pour le maître ministre de
l'aménagement du territoire de l'
équilibre des territoires
vous pensez que tout est pareil entre
roussel nous mélenchon qu'est ce qui
diffère par exemple vous et jean levi's
sait pas quand on sait qu'outre les uns
les autres a l'impression que les
différents ça se voit un petit peu quand
même et je suis sûr qu'ils feraient un
magnifique ministre de l'aménagement du
territoire pour rassembler les français
l'union des droites c'est l'appel que je
lance ici vous qui avez cru en le pen
pasqua séguin villiers sarkozy fillon
ces gens qui veulent faire l'union en
divisant qui veulent gagner en
prétendant que les autres ne peut pas
faire alors qu'ils sont en queue de
peloton dans les sondages moi ça me
laisse pantois je pense que tout ça
c'est un cirque médiatique plus de 4000
personnes se sont déplacées pour le
meeting d'eric zemmour l'occasion de
célébrer les derniers ralliements et
notamment un ancien proche de marine le
pen gilbert collard vous avez marine le
pen qui est le produit d'origine vous
avez le tandem pécresse ce type qui a un
peu la copie et puis vous avez et moore
qui est le bac à recyclage qui récupère
un peu tout le monde fait ce qui aura
d'autres départs des républicains issus
à zidane aura pas et moi je suis un
homme de chez vous le savez il affirmait
vous le savez il ya l'odeur de fidélité
je crois la fidélité à la parole donnée
hier à dire très clairement que je n'ai
strictement rien contre marine le pen et
je ne dirai jamais rien entre ce type de
comportement la manière dont ils le font
l'absence de courage ne serait-ce que de
me passe un coup de téléphone pour me
dire on s'en va et immoral c'est c'est
ce qui dégoûte je crois les français de
la politique moi je voudrais dire aux
français c'est important quand même qu'
il ne se fixe pas sur ces gens là ces
gens là ils sont une minorité fidèle à
des convictions tu préfères ton pays at
on parle et goethe accueille les bras
ouverts jean-jacques savin un aventurier
de 75 au raid s'était lancé un défi fou
traverser l'atlantique en solitaire à la
rame à bord d'une petite embarcation
il était parti le 1er janvier dernier
cela faisait quelques jours qu'on avait
plus de nouvelles de lui il a été
retrouvé mort hier
[Rires]
hier après-midi la sécurité maritimes
portugaises retrouve son canot retourné
au large des açores à l'intérieur son
corps sans vie a plus d'argent passé
france prévue dans vraiment l'ordinateur
avrillé
fiscale c'est légal